lleva el ambiente de semifinal aquí a
las afueras del estadio de luz el
estadio más grande de esta copa mundo
vamos a ver si se rompe el récord de
asistencia que se tiene de esta copa
mundo partido Precisamente en el que
estuvo Argentina en ese Duelo contra los
mexicanos la albiceleste que en unos
minutos nos va a despejar la duda de
quién estará ocupando ese lateral
izquierdo en el que no estará Marcos
Acuña suspendido por tarjetas amarilla
amarillas y veremos si finalmente es
Nicolás tagliafico el hombre que apunta
hacia el titular para ese partido de la
otra interrogante es sobre si finalmente
Rodrigo de Paul estará de inicialista y
viene con unas molestias de Paul que es
uno de los cuatro hombres que siempre ha
sido titular para Lionel scaloni con los
croatas no se prevén cambios este equipo
ha jugado cinco partidos con nueve
jugadores que han repetido como
inicialistas la única duda es quien
acompañaría a cramer en la delantera
ambiente de final aquí en luz hay
solamente un equipo pasará a la final la
Argentina de Lionel Messi o la Croacia
de Luka modric